so I'd stay away from the genetics and
back to the brain scans you cut that out
now or you'll go home in an ambulance
yeah that seems mildly inappropriate for
a political discussion no I know no way
to be fair but yeah
but to be fair you're actually being hey
guys rude no no and that's not fair
why is this synth ass a dude did you
hear him to be fair you're being kind of
rude so this dude can hit him how are
you simping for a dude just because he's
in a dress can you imagine that level of
simp you're simping for a dude
if two men were in an argument nobody
would care but because this dude has a
dress on now we need to cater to him
whatever